buckle up we begin with the Fox News
Alert the president set to take the
stage any moment now in Phoenix Arizona
we will take you there live as it
happens but first we start with the
president well blasting many Mike the
farmer Bloomberg from earlier today
probably a preview of coming attractions
for tonight take a look this meeting
Kevin was just saying was set up long
before Devin and Kevin set it up long
before we heard that many Mike hates the
farmer long before we learned about his
hatred of the farmer disrespect of the
farmer so I don't know I don't think
he's gonna be the candidate anyway
America is a nation built by farmers who
work hard to provide their family
support their neighbors and draw out
God's abundance from the earth you pour
out your sweat and soul you pour out
your heart you really do you're
incredible people you work so hard and
you're smart as hell why I will always
keep fighting for the American farmer
and rancher the people in this room
we're going to fight for you and we're
gonna win and we're gonna get you your
water and put a lot of pressure on your
governor and frankly if he doesn't do it
you're gonna get a new governor we all
need to thank our farmers the hard work
they do and it takes a lot of skill
advanced degrees in many cases that's
probably a preview of what's coming up
in just moments we'll have it what it
happens live the president will I'm sure
be addressing many Mike the former
Bloomberg will have it live this hour
and as per usual Trump supporters they
started lining up well over 24 hours ago
some even camping out overnight to get a
spot inside we're gonna check on Phoenix
coming up and throughout the hour we
have an exclusive by the way Hannity
investigation as it relates to the mini
Mike the farmer Bloomberg and his crazy
points of view our own Lawrence Jones is
in Vegas tonight where he's asking
Democrats what they really think about
this week well filled and the chaos that
has broken out in the primary but first
it's time for a quick roundup of all of
the out-of-touch Democratic candidates
that want to be your next president now
the clear front-runner is Bolshevik
Bernie Sanders yep about socialist even
in the former Soviet Union he now has a
double-digit lead in the
RealClearPolitics national average but
like any good Soviet style socialist
he's keeping some pretty big secrets
after just a few months after the 78
year old senator suffered a massive
heart attack on the campaign trail he is
now refusing to release any of his
medical records anymore that is and
according to Bolshevik Bernie it
shouldn't matter because voting for him
is like voting for Nelson Mandela you
heard me right you can't even make this
up take a look I think it back some of
you may be familiar with Nelson Mandela
habitat and his fight for freedom in
South Africa and people marching to the
polls and thinkin about the civil rights
movement of people marching to the polls
well we're fighting to change America
let's go out I think the polling booths
are pretty close to here's the right
Student Union Building all right let's
take a little walk let's vote let's
change America thank you
really bolshevik Bernie Nelson Mandela
his socialist utopia meaning yours
Bernie anyway in reality
well Bolshevik Bernie soviet-era
policies will cause untold damage to
this country to the American people
wants to nationalize the energy industry
nationalize the healthcare industry by
the way confiscation private business
private property massive huge tax
increases for all Americans even capping
the amount of money you can make
and of course Medicare for all which we
can't afford you will destroy the single
best economy in the world frankly it's
kind of scary
this radical candidate could very well
be the Democratic nominee frankly they
all scare me and while Bernie Sanders
the Bolshevik is declared war on free
market capitalism one of his challengers
and we have mayor Pete Buda judge
attacking Christians all over America
take a look at this do you think it is
impossible to be a Christian and support
President Trump well I'm not going to
tell other Christians how to be
Christians but I will say I cannot find
any compatibility between the way this
president conducts himself and anything
I find in Scripture now I guess that's
my interpretation but I think that's a
lot of people's interpretation and that
interpretation deserves the best okay
you're a Christian and you support
Donald Trump looks like mayor Pete is
looking down on you and to think you
know I believe as a sinner I plead
guilty sinner right here all right we
seek out our God and Jesus wide to
change our hearts to make us better
people for Jesus to forgive us our sins
our imperfections and deliver us from
evil
whatever our sins happened to be as an
individual that he came and He gave His
life so we all can live all of us but
clearly there are people that will now
question your faith our faith because of
political differences well that's taking
Trump derangement to a whole new level
and here we go again I guess another
Democrat that thinks we the people
irredeemable deplorable smelly Walmart
shoppers that support Donald Trump
I guess he's probably thinking we cling
to our God our Constitution or Bibles
and religion and then to top it off he
doesn't even care if we lose our health
insurance because his socialized
Medicare for all will take care of
everybody just trust mayor Pete take a
look the insurance companies by the way
do not like my plan they attacked at the
moment it came out because they don't
want the competition the question of
whether it leaves it private insurance
intact that's actually up to the
insurance companies either they'll come
up with something better
that'll compete with the plan I'm
putting out there or they'll fail and to
be honest I don't care I don't care if
you lose your health care that's the
candidate who thinks the Democrat they
actually think he's a moderate
democratic party is now devolved into
one big radical socialist organization
and perhaps mayor Pete self-important
arrogant holier-than-thou attitude is
just one reason he's struggling to
garner support from anyone who
apparently is not in his demographic
that's not stopping his campaign from
pretending oh they're pretending not to
have minority support they don't have
this ABC news report mayor pique caught
on multiple occasions boasting about
endorsements from african-american
leaders that his campaign never received
whoops by the way what does the Bible
say about that now that were quoting the
Bible oh you shall know the truth and
the truth shall set you free and
naturally is not the only
crying so hard to pander for votes
take a look at this painfully bizarre
awkward moment in this case it's Amy
Klobuchar so let me tell you first about
me my name is Amy and when when I was
took Spanish in 4th grade my name was
Elena I think Amy the name Fiamma Elena
Elena because I couldn't roll my arse
very very well and so with ele na so
while Coppa chars cringe-worthy campaign
might make you want to crawl out of your
skin it pales in comparison to some of
the rhetoric coming from yep
America's great farmer with a lot of
gray matter that would be mini Mike
Bloomberg every time he opens his mouth
well what do we get something elitist
arrogant and frankly ignorant and beyond
offensive coming out we're poorly making
dozens of crude analogies between sales
and having sex with women according to
various lawsuits I wish I could say this
stuff on the air if I did I'd have to
deal with it a you know management would
be mad for a while allegedly has a nasty
habit of screaming at his employees
especially pregnant women one woman
claiming encouraged her to get an
abortion telling her to kill it but
that's not all he once said that black
and Latino employees don't know how to
behave in the workplace and he said of
course that all the crime not so all the
crime is happening in minority
neighborhoods and that all criminals fit
one mo minority 16 to 25 according to
bloomberg you just take that description
Xerox it and pass it out to all the cops
and in 2011 Bloomberg also delivered
some shocking remarks directed at
American seniors actually called for
health care rationing for the elderly
that the US government should tell of 96
year old we cancer quote have a nice day
it lived a long life there's no cure
we're not gonna do anything for you
pretty much the go home and die approach
to health care of oh the billionaire so
what if a person is 86 farmer Mike or 76
where does farmer Mike's Medicare
rationing begin and at what age do these
death panels of
kick in farmer Mike we're looking for
answers I don't quite have the gray
matter that allows me to comprehend
you're pretty sick and cows genius and
let's not also forget farmer Mike's
totally aloof smug insulting comments
about America's great farmers he said I
could teach anyone to be a farmer he
could teach anybody at all to be a
farmer and that Kate you just dig a hole
and you put seed in it put dirt on top
of that add water and up comes your corn
oh I didn't know is that easy take a
look the agrarian society lasted 3000
years and we could teach processes I
could teach anybody even people in this
room just don't know offence intended to
be a farmer you it's a processor you dig
a hole you put up the seed in you put
dirt on top add water up comes the corn
then we had 300 you could learn that and
the information economy is fundamentally
different because it's built around
replacing people with technology and the
skill sets that you have to learn are
how to think and analyze and that is a
whole degree level different you have to
have a different skill set you have to
have a lot more grey matter a lot more
gray matter unlike the farmers like
jagged deeds anybody to farm that gets
right to the heart of what arrogant
elitist politicians think about we the
people we have the greatest farmers in
the history of the world they feed us
and the world we pointed out last night
our great American farmers they work at
incredibly complex new agricultural
technology sophisticated industry I mean
they get advanced degrees from some of
the most prestigious programs all across
America and it's because of that gray
matter and ingenuity and tireless work
they feed this country in the entire
world